[Music]
hi welcome to another episode of Cold
Fusion
in 1990 three percent of Americans said
that they had no close friends in 2021
this number has risen to 15 percent
sadly the trend is in the same direction
all across the world
so here's a question if billions of us
around the world are so connected
through social media why are we so
lonely
well as it turns out the connections
made through social media aren't as real
as we once thought what's worse is that
some sociologists think that social
media has actually created a simulation
of reality a simulation that we mistake
for reality itself
this can drive social Division and make
us miserable we'll cover all of this
later in the episode but first we'll
talk about a new app called be real
be real promises to strip away the
fakeness and bring back authenticity to
social media and people are responding
by mid-2022 it became the number one
downloaded app on the app store in the
United States and the most downloaded
app in Australia Germany and many other
countries so what is be real will it
last and what does it tell us about the
direction Society might be heading
you are watching cold fusion TV
[Music]
when social media first gained
popularity in the 2010s it was and still
is a great tool to stay in contact with
people all around the world but since
then we've lost our innocence
countless scandals and whistleblowers
have painted virtually every platform as
a detriment to society
it literally is a point now
where I think we have created tools that
are ripping apart the social fabric of
how Society works that is truly Where We
Are
if you feed the beast that Beast will
destroy you
if you push back on it we have a chance
to control it and Reign it in
and it is a point in time where people
need to hard break from some of these
tools and the things that you rely on
the short-term dopamine driven feedback
loops that we have created are
destroying how Society works
it is eroding the core foundations of
how people behave
by and between each other right we
curate our lives around this perceived
sense of perfection
because we get rewarded in these
short-term signals Hearts likes thumbs
up and we conflate that with value and
we conflate it with truth and it's not
an American problem this is a global
problem
people are now consciously aware of the
negative effects and are starting to
move away on the back of this trend be
real rose to prominence it aimed to be
the anti-social media social media
so what is b-real exactly
be real is a French social media app
released in 2020 it was developed by
Alexis barriad a former GoPro employee
the application basically sat around for
two years before suddenly exploding in
popularity in mid-2022 the basic concept
of be real is simple once you download
the app you get a notification once a
day when it's time to quote be real this
means you have two minutes to take a
photo of whatever you're doing no matter
how mundane the app takes a dual photo
so that is a selfie and then another
photo of what you're doing there's no
option for videos on the service yet
according to the company quote push
notifications are sent around the world
simultaneously at different times each
day it's a secret on how the time is
chosen every day it's not random
the result is the social feed filled
with unedited photos of people doing
every day unglamorous things
eating food watching a movie at home
doing homework riding the bus just
everyday things
there are two main tabs your friends tab
which is just posed from people on your
contacts list or the discovery where you
can follow other people if you wish
the biggest difference and the most
standout thing is just how Bare Bones
and basic the app is really it's the
opposite of Instagram in every way it's
actually on the verge of being boring
but that's the point
I guess today in social media we're so
used to shiny bells and dopamine hacks
to hold our attention and when that's
all taken away social media can seem
extremely dry
there's no algorithm that shows you what
to see there's no light counters no
filters no editing no advertisements
just ordinary pictures of people and
comments there's only one post per day
so there's no cluttering of your feet
it's really just a simple snapshot of
what your friends or people around the
world are doing at that particular point
in time
despite looking boring from the outside
the app has seen immense success this
year alone downloads have grown by at
least 315 percent at least 65 percent of
these lifetime downloads happened in the
first quarter of 2022 and interestingly
gen Z are the majority of the users
in August of 2022 be real became the
most downloaded app in Germany and the
popularity has grown internationally
Fiji even became the first country with
an official account the company has now
received 600 million dollars in funding
and this is set to grow as of July 2022
the app has over 20 million estimated
Global installs and it has a decent
active user base with over 10 million
active daily users
but it can't all be sunshine and Roses
as interesting as this app is right now
I can see be real failing in one of
three ways number one people just get
bored of it number two be real adds more
features until it loses its identity and
becomes just another social media app
or three Instagram could just steal the
feature which is rumored to already be
in the works and aside from all of this
the company still needs a way to figure
out how to generate Revenue there's no
ads on the platform at all
but regardless of what happens the fact
that this app has become so popular
among younger people is a signal to me
it highlights that there's an appetite
and demand for a different type of
social media a social media that is
healthier and just maybe the online
space of the future could be healthier
too
I do hope to see this scenario unfold
whether it's from be real or another
player I'm sure a lot of you also would
be confused and quickly quip why don't
these kids just go outside and talk to
people but for many people it's just not
so easy if we can have healthier ways of
connecting online I don't think there's
anything wrong with that
so let's look into this a little deeper
what does this explosive growth of this
app tell us about Society
whether it's images or information
social media is often over curated as
time has gone on this has caused social
media to largely Force Society into a
state of hyper reality hyper reality is
a term coined by French sociologist sure
Borderland in 1981 a hyper real scenario
features a world where the simulations
of reality are indistinguishable from
reality itself the real world and the
simulated world no longer have
boundaries as a consequence nothing in
our culture is true anymore all that
we're left with is a representation or a
copy of reality
some may argue that we're not quite at
that point yet but this theory has
lately been applied to social media
it goes something like this all the
pictures that we post links that we
share messages we type and media that we
consume online creates a personalized
world that's different from The Real
World in our minds this Digital World
replaces reality give it enough time and
the digital reality becomes more
important to us than the real world
further to this the algorithms will
dictate exactly how your digital world
will look like as time progresses all of
our digital worlds drift further away
from what is truly real
for example a lot of major controversies
on Twitter don't exist in the real world
another common example is the lives that
you see others living on Instagram isn't
reality
so what does this all have to do with be
real well this app might be an
interesting way of tackling this hyper
reality while having the convenience of
staying digitally connected
philosophically I find that very
interesting regardless of if I'm going
to personally use this app or not
speaking of which I have used the app
for a bit and I don't think it's for me
but upon reading what others are saying
people are really liking it
the main consensus is that the app is
actually authentic people tend to only
have their close friends instead of the
thousands of Instagram followers that
may be strangers to them they State
there's less pressure to look good and
this creates a judgment-free Zone and
overall it makes the app feel more down
to earth and for many social media users
I can see how this can be refreshing
and as a final side this episode isn't
sponsored I haven't been in contact or
received anything from be real this is
just my commentary on society just a bit
of a different episode on something that
I purely just found interesting
so anyways let me know what you guys
thought do you think be real will
succeed or will it fail and do you think
will ever collectively Escape hyper
reality let me know your thoughts in the
comments section below
so that's about it from me my name is
dagogo and you've been watching cold
fusion and I'll catch you again soon for
the next episode cheers guys have a good
one
[Music]
even when it seems like everybody's
against you
that one person
[Music]